Phong qua hai bây giờ sảo tháng 6 năm 2020, đường an tất sang,
được lượng hàng mắt tại giải gần ra công bố vide lo cho thấy một tay súng trẻ về viết
rát trẻ của U.S.R.N. Chaolin-Sé thả động nổ duyên từ định hình qua cơ nốc đang bởi giới
sức luy. Nếu đạn phát nổ bên trong xe, thiến chứ của mà bốc trái giữ rồi,
bày quân nhìn thực tìu đàn công bình số sảo chăm linh năm,
lượng đàn thiết sát số một trong tạm miếng tạm thiệt mạng.
Lực lượng Phong P.E.S.R.N. TDF trước đó thùng máo, bụt tính công sẻ ra tại thành phố Khanh Yulis,
diễn năm dải gà ra, không hai mi tư tháng 6 năm 2020, nhưng cho rằng
thành biên thà mắt đã gái bóng tự trễ vàng xe.
TDF đang tìm dự lượng xe có được trong bị cà mera giám sát hài không.
Lại cà mera này tương xuất hiện trên nhiều thiết sát chờ quân đời cố,
thuộc bên trẻ thất tiểu bàn dự bị chùi yếu thông qua những sáng kiến cấp đơn vị
hoặc xa quân dinh tự bỏ tiền mua. Tiểu bàn công biên xấu trang liên năm là đến
bị chính quyền, phải tương thuộc quy định nghiêm là tệ lắp đã thiết bị năm 2020,
giù chúng có thể giúp quân dinh phát hiện đối phương đang thiết tận.